korban nearly stolen it is viola default  palace in' lives in a head on the deep  on the fake throws it down and turner  grabs the rebound  Oladipo sneaks past james layup won't go  gets the rebound couple of fakes Nance  got a piece of the LOD post still packed  at home on James  stolen by Oladipo Stevenson back to  Oladipo  [Applause]  [Music]  actually Stevenson stays in the game so  [Applause]  on the depot Maxim home have to get rid  of it with the shot clock expiring  [Music]  Oladipo  attacking and finishing over the top  here  just blow but blows by junior Smith no  help and finishes Oladipo gets away from  Nance fine Sabonis Sabonis one-handed  banks it in from straight on well now  he's playing better because he's one  floor assist closer to triple-double